where does Russia stand as does Russia
care whether Britain exits the EU or not
Russia cares about Europe we do need
strong partner with Europe our key
partner in the world
weak partners are usually not good
partners not safe partners so we need
you to stay strong so depends if europe
is not going to become weaker because of
the brexit then we are ok with that but
if europe is going to become weaker and
you'll have problems also in terms of
economy and overall economic development
stance then we are not in favor of that
but i would like to reiterate that the
sovereign right of people who live in
the UK and nobody should intervene to
that yeah you'll be aware that a lot of
people in Europe and in Britain believe
that Russia would be delighted if the UK
was to exit the European Union because
maybe Russia wants a weaker Europe maybe
that would make it easier to end the
sanctions that not true that's not true
that's not true and true belief is that
only really strong countries and strong
unions can serve as instance for
stability around the world and strong
Europe was very important for us
EU is Russia's biggest trading partner I
know president younger and President
Putin have had an opportunity to meet
did you get any sense that there's light
at the end of the tunnel when it comes
to the sanctions that have been imposed
against Russia from that meeting
sanctions are imposed by Europe by
United States some other countries and
we cannot influence that we are working
we are doing our best to keep our
economy on track yeah economy is for I
think now so it's more less stable
already
we believe that sanctions are
counterproductive for everyone yeah not
for us but for Europe as well as for
United States and other countries
and sooner sanctions will be revoked the
better the world we've heard the central
bank say the Russian central bank that
you can you know sort of get to positive
growth maybe by the end of the year
you're looking at maybe one and a half
percent next year my question you would
be can Russia ever get beyond two
percent as long as those sanctions are
in place or is that as good as it gets
most of the growth depends not on
sanctions not on oil prices but on our
own policies to promote growth
structural reforms institutional reforms
better business environment better
science and education things like that
sanctions have only minor effect on that
oil price cap temporary effect not
long-term effect so we should work
better to achieve higher rates of growth
and it is possible to achieve three to
four percent growth in the medium term
prospects even with sanctions even with
sanctions
we heard former president former french
President Nicolas Sarkozy today say
Russia should as a gesture to get beyond
sanctions break the impasse perhaps drop
some of its counter sanctions Russia has
banned a lot of EU imports particularly
in the food sector as a way to sort of
begin the the thaw with the European
Union is that something that Russia
would entertain or is that the EU that
has to make the first move
we are not in the entertainment business
we are not in the charity world charity
is important but not in this case right
how food and bars are not talking about
charity we're talking about you it's not
about gestures our Putin burger was
introduced as a compensation mechanism
for our agricultural producers since
were in this tuition were financing
conditions worsened dramatically
yeah after sanctions so it's the
compensation for that and if you will
revoke embargo we are going to
compensate for still bad financing
conditions only taxpayers money but we
don't have lots of those we have a
strict budget constraint so we need to
keep this compensation policy in place
until sanctions and it's working you
think four hours the ability s Russian
agriculture is basically the only sector
growing and sustainable matter over the
last three years which became the
largest grain producer a grain exporter
in the world this agricultural here it
is very important for us since they
getting good profits and invest back to
Russia and we continue to increase our
food production so it is working you and
I have been coming to this Investment
Forum for the better part of a decade
what's your sense of investor appetite
particularly amongst foreigners is it
improving I saw more than 20 companies
to the already on the first few hours of
the forum its new building new
facilities so everyone is looking at the
environment with the interest but most
important thing is that everyone is in
the process of investment investing more
money in international Konya in the
process of creating new industrial
facilities new are Indian
projects and creating even new research
labs in Russia with Russian universities
everyone there's no single exception
among those more than 20 companies those
companies are from United States from
Europe from China from Japan and other
countries so they find the pose
different they all believe that it will
be better to do things without sanctions
without confrontation but they continue
doing business in Russia and with Russia
from the basis of long-term interest
talk to me about your privatization
program one of the companies on the
block that you're looking at privatizing
is I'll row so it's the world's largest
diamond producer is it possible that we
could see a share sale in Alrosa or a
strategic sale as soon as this month we
have a number of companies preparing for
privatization of stakes in some cases a
minor and some is bigger yeah Melrose is
among those Bosnia SOCOM float Rosneft a
couple of others also on the list
timing will depend on the elimination of
the markets by the gum to buy by
respective companies sir
so I cannot tell you the exact dates or
even months well since we're in Judea in
the process effective preparation for
that you're in the process of preparing
the prospectus for a share sale or not
necessarily in some case we are still
defining the right structure of
translation transaction whether we are
going to to attract strategic investors
of portfolios in this particular case
ex-ante sentir you know decisions will
be based on soro market research sure we
only have another minute talk to me
about one of the companies you mentioned
roast half the world's large publicly
traded oil producer you want to sell a
stake in it one government official said
hey maybe one way we can do it is we can
sell a strategics
stake to say the chinese we know they're
interested maybe the Indians I'm not
sure if they're interested for
attendance for the Italians is that on
the cards are the Italians interested we
are in the process of this discussion is
this all our strategic partners
we will see with all the talents I hear
today the forum including the Prime
Minister we will see what is the recent
interest but we cannot we cannot exclude
any a possibility you have a very good
relationship with Chinese partners with
Indian partners so we will have the real
negotiation process one thing we know is
that BP isn't going to increase its
stake they've already said that there
are 20% they're happy you know because a
is a share sale also possible like maybe
you could do both have a strategic sale
for part of it options on the table and
finally the very last question very
quickly dividends right one of the
things that investors loved about what
the government had to say is you're
gonna pay out you want the state
companies to pay out 50 percent of their
profit and dividends and then they have
watched as a bunch of the companies have
gotten exceptions we won't get into the
details for various reasons are you
worried there's a little bit of a
credibility problem in the sense that
you you've said you want one thing and a
lot of the companies are simply escaping
you're here well I think the overall
trend and the position of the government
that dividend should be higher is a very
clear sign of what we are doing but
specific individual decisions are
possible since the world is more complex
than we think from the very beginning